son propre télé pour la seconde année
consécutive le nombre de cambriolages a
augmenté plus 6% en 2012 dans les
Yvelines certes le chiffre de plus de
18% de hausse de 2011 ABC mais la
progression demeure pour répondre à ces
infractions l'accent est mis sur la
Polytechnique et scientifique
aujourd'hui nous résolvons dans ce
département comme au niveau national une
dizaine de % des cambriolages donc ce
taux
mérite d'être amélioré
68 policiers polyvalents former sont
désormais dévolus en partie à cette
tâche en amont ces policiers signalisent
les individus mise en cause dans un fait
de délinquance les empreintes sont
archivées dans les fichiers de la police
sur les lieux des infractions les agents
prélèvent les traces éventuelles
laissées par les auteurs afin de
comparer ces indices avec les données
archivées traces ADN papillaire
empreinte sur place rien n'est négligé
la première mission c'est la protection
des tracés indices la deuxième étape
très importante c'est la fixation des
lieux au moyen de photographie les
indices biologiques récoltés sont
protégés afin d'être
ultérieurement examinés pour 100 hauteur
identifiées 50 le son grâce à la police
technique et scientifique 35 grâce à un
témoin 15% grâce à l'enquête rappelons
que la prévention reste la meilleure des
protections fermées porte et fenêtres en
partant si possible faire installer une
alarme et prévenir le commissariat ou la
gendarmerie en cas de départ prolongé